all right turning to a story overseas a
member of iran's elite revolutionary
guard is charged in an alleged plot to
murder former national security adviser
john bolton the justice department says
that bolton of course a longtime critic
of iran was targeted after a u.s attack
killed a top iranian general in 2020.
senior investigative correspondent
catherine herridge spoke with bolton
about the case catherine what a story
here good morning
good morning tony multiple sources tell
cbs news this was a serious plot the
iranian defendant was not a rogue actor
and the threat extends to other former
government officials
investigators say the alleged murder for
hire plot began to take shape after this
drone strike in iraq assassinated top
iranian general qasim suleimani over two
years ago former national security
adviser john bolton quickly tweeted
congratulations to all involved iran
vowed retaliation the justice department
is now charging sharam prasafi a member
of iran's revolutionary guard with
offering three hundred thousand dollars
to murder bolton what did the fbi say
about the serious nature of the threat
they were able to confirm that it was
potentially an effort either to kidnap
me or assassinate me according to newly
released law enforcement records porsavi
working from iran hired operatives to
surveil and then eliminate bolton even
texting pictures of cash promising
handsome payments separately sources
told cbs news another target of the
iranian plot included former secretary
of state mike pompeo what poor sofi
didn't know is that he was dealing with
an fbi confidential source a lot of this
is done
with the secrecy bill evening ran
counter-intelligence operations during
the trump administration the threat does
not go away at all to
ambassador bolton or any other official
that iran has their targets on with
talks to revive the 2015 nuclear deal
with iran bolton warned the white house
against engagement i think there's no
doubt that there are other plots and not
just against former government officials
against
innocent american civilians it tells you
the very nature of the regime in tehran
that this is the kind of terrorist
regime they are
wilton now has the same level of secret
service protection he had while working
at the white house nate iran denies any
involvement
catherine thank you